the mayor of charlottesville virginia
democratic mayor mayor nikuya walker
tweeted a bizarre and vulgar poem
wednesday
comparing her city the city that she is
supposed to lead
to a rapist poem i'll read you the poem
maybe this would be my good snap poetry
sort of you know
the beautiful ugly it is it lynched you
hung
the noose at city hall and pressed the
souvenir that was once
your finger against its lips it covers
your death with its good intentions it
is a place where white women with black
kids collects
collects signature for a white man who
questions whether a black woman
understands white supremacy huh what's
going on
it is destructively world-class
destructively world-class
white people say that it is a place
where gentrification started with the
election of a black woman in 2017
and because of white power a lie becomes
facts
its daily practice is that of separating
you from your soul
this is the city that she's the mayor of
charlottesville is a void
of a moral is void of a moral compass
it's as if good old thomas jefferson is
still cleverly using his whip to whip
the current inhabitants
into submissiveness charlottesville
rapes you of your breaths
it suffocates you of your hopes and
dreams oh gosh lady this place sounds
terrible i won't i won't finish it
you can read the rest of the poem if you
want she says you know the city's rooted
in white supremacy and racism and all
that kind of stuff
she probably shouldn't be the mayor of
this town right
if you if you don't love your
town you probably shouldn't be in
service of your town
right you you probably shouldn't lead
your town if you hate it
if you hate your country you probably
shouldn't lead your country
in a way this is a form of false modesty
too because this woman is not saying i'm
bad
she's not saying i i have problems and i
am contributing to the problems in this
community
she's saying everybody else is every
other
ev every problem in the whole world is
someone else's fault
but it's never her so she says you know
it's this town that i'm the leader of
it's really
terrible and bad but not me i'm the good
one you know but but oh everyone's
really terrible here
it's a great true form of pride it's
completely
uh tone deaf to the realities of of
human brokenness and original sin
but this is also a form of filial
impiety the reason we
we ought to love our countries the
reason it's right and just to love your
country and be
a patriot is because of filial piety
it's an extension of the natural
obligation you have
of loyalty duty and even love
for your family and then you extend that
more broadly and you get
up to the nation and beyond the nation
for that matter
this is a form of filial impact it's
very ugly even people who live in not
great countries when they just turn on
their country it's ugly just like if you
hear someone bad-mouthing his family
or bad-mouthing his community it's just
ugly even if some criticism is warranted
you think this kind of disdain this
contempt is really really wrong
stuff if you enjoyed that break from
disinformation historical revision
and screaming about the end of the world
be sure to hit the subscribe button
so that you never miss another video
[Music]
[Music]